Olá hoje eu vou falar sobre os oito
alimentos que danificam as suas artérias
são alimentos inflamatórios que entopem
as suas artérias causam coágulos no
sangue e aumenta o risco de infarto e
AVC são verdadeiras porcarias
alimentícias que mais causam doenças no
mundo então Esse vídeo é muito
importante você pode pensar que não
consome nenhum desses alimentos que eu
vou mencionar ou que consome apenas de
vez em quando
mas muitas vezes as pessoas começam a
perceber que mesmo consumindo de vez em
quando acabam ingerindo um deles
diariamente no final estão consumindo
essas porcarias todos os dias colocando
o veneninho na sua saúde causando
inflamação crônica muitos vão pensar que
a carne vermelha por conter gordura
saturada é o primeiro alimento dessa
lista Mas fique tranquilo porque isso
não é verdade Ignore essas recomendações
errôneas sobre a carne vermelha e a
gordura saturada causarem doenças
cardíacas pois não há comprovação
inequívoca de que fazem isso eu vou
deixar um vídeo na descrição sobre essa
grande mentira em relação às carnes
quando eu falo de Carnes refiro-me as
carnes em Natura e não as embutidas
frios linguiças e outros produtos
industrializados Ok então não deixe de
conferir esse vídeo na descrição antes
de falar dos alimentos é importante ter
Ender os problemas que envolvem nossas
artérias a camada interior das artérias
chamada de camada endotelial pode sofrer
uma disfunção devido à inflamação
crônica Então essa inflamação pode levar
a uma fibrose do tecido acúmulo de
cálcio colesterol e outras substâncias
que estreitam e endurecem as paredes das
artérias quando esses coágulos se soltam
podem causar ataques cardíacos e até
derrames o que pode causar essa
inflamação nas paredes das artérias com
risco até de formação de coágulos isso
acontece quando você tem resistência à
insulina Ou seja quando a sua insulina
fica muito alta a insulina elevada causa
inflamação no interior das artérias
tornando-as espessas e disformes
aumentando o risco de formação de
coágulos e essa inflamação nas artérias
danificadas ocorre pelo consumo
excessivo de carboidratos refinados e
açúcares Além disso o consumo de
vegetais e sementes e gordura trans
também contribuem muito pra inflamação
porque levam estress oxidativo ou seja
danos oxidativos às Paredes das artérias
promovendo desenvolvimento de
arterosclerose e coágulos outra causa
que contribui é a deficiência de
nutrientes importantes como a vitamina D
A K2 antioxidantes em geral e
principalmente eletrólitos como potássio
e magnésio que ajudam a diminuir a
rigidez das artérias e evitam a pressão
alta a pressão alta por sua vez é
causada pela resistência à insulina
diabetes obesidade todos relacionados à
alimentação entendendo esses vilões
Vamos aos alimentos o alimento número um
são torradas e pão seja o pão francês ou
aquele de saquinho de mercado Sabe
aquele pão na chapa ou aquela torrada do
seu café da manhã quando você consome
regularmente isso contribui para a
inflamação das paredes arteriais isso
ocorre por causa de alguns fatores entre
eles a formação de acrilamida que é uma
substância química que se forma em
alimentos ricos em carboidratos e
gorduras quando são preparados em altas
temperaturas Como torrar ou assar quando
você torra o pão ou come a torrada ou
faz o pão na chapa com margarina isso
produz a acrilamida que está associada a
danos no endotélio vascular por oxidação
aumentando a inflamação e
consequentemente o risco de doenças
cardiovasculares além da cril amida ou
pão torrado ou a torrada também são
problemáticos porque são feitos com
farinhas refinadas que são processadas e
ricas em carboidratos simples que se
consumidos em acesso esses carboidratos
aumentam os níveis de insulina associado
a um estado inflamatório inclusive do
endotélio arterial então esses alimentos
também afetam negativamente o equilíbrio
de magnésio no nosso corpo o consumo
exagerado dessas farinhas refinadas
aumenta a necessidade de magnésio para o
metabolismo do açúcar o que pode esgotar
nossas reservas de magnésio o magnésio é
essencial para o relaxamento dos
músculos arteriais prevenção da pressão
alta e Hipertensão impedimento na
calcificação e endurecimento das
artérias artério esclerose então com
esse tipo de produto temos aumento da
insulina formação de acrilamida que é
tóxica para as artérias e diminuição do
magnésio essencial para a saúde de
nossas veias e artérias Então esse tipo
de alimento deve ser consumido de vez
enquando e não pode fazer parte da sua
rotina diária o alimento número dois são
os
refrigerantes não há muito que explicar
que você já deve saber há muito tempo
que os refrigerantes São péssimos para
saúde saúde incluindo as nossas artérias
e veias na realidade o refrigerante é
ruim pro nosso organismo como todo
refrigerantes e sucos industrializados
contém uma grande quantidade de açúcar e
esse açúcar aumenta os nível de insulina
promovendo resistência insulínica e
inflamação O problema é que é fácil
tomar vários copos de refrigerante ao
dia e esquecer a quantidade de açúcar e
outras substâncias ruins danosa que
essas bebidas contém que vão causar
inflamação crônica então não há muito
mais o que falar sobre refrigerantes na
verdade eu fiz um vídeo só sobre os
perigos do refrigerante e eu vou deixar
o link desse vídeo na descrição o
alimento número TR pode ser uma surpresa
para muitos que é o sorvete o sorvete é
considerado um dos piores alimentos pra
saúde das artérias e pode realmente
impactar de forma negativa a sua saúde
cardíaca estou falando do sorvete
industrializado aqueles cremosos que vem
potes geralmente 2 l ou mesmo dos
sorvetes de massa que você compra em
vários lugares e nem sabe quais são os
ingredientes corretos esse tipo de
sorvete é rico em primeiramente açúcar e
segundo gorduras trans como eu já
mencionei o açúcar leva inflamação
crônica resistência à insulina
contribuindo paraa formação de placas e
coágulos muitos tipos de sorvete também
contm tem gordura trans conhecida como
gordura vegetal hidrogenada conhecida
por aumentar os níveis de colesterol LDL
oxidado que causa inflamação nas paredes
das artérias Além disso os sorvetes
contêm compostos de leite em uma
proporção muito alta de cálcio e o
consumo excessivo de leite
industrializado pode levar ao acúmulo de
cálcio nas paredes arteriais
contribuindo pra calcificação arterial o
sentes muitas vezes contém ingredientes
artificiais conservantes corantes e
outros aditivos que também promove
inflamação crônica Pessoal consuma esse
tipo de alimento de forma esporádica
procure fazer o seu próprio sorvete em
casa com ingredientes naturais e o mais
saudáveis que você encontrar sem a
gordura trans prejudicial Ok o alimento
quatro é a famosa margarina que
provavelmente você utiliza com o
alimento número um pãozinho ou torrada
Quantas pessoas no Brasil comem pão ou
torrada com margarina todos os dias
muitas pessoas acham que a margarina é
mais saudável que manteiga mas não é bem
assim pessoal hoje em dia as margarinas
não são mais feitas totalmente de
gordura hidrogenada mas são feitas a
partir de óleos vegetais que passam por
um processo artificial que envolve
hidrogenação parcial transformando o
óleo líquido em gordura sólidas esse
processo faz a margarina espalhar melhor
no pão mas mesmo assim a margarina é
composta de conservantes estabilizantes
gorduras artificialmente criadas a
partir desses óleos vegetais modificados
tudo isso é altamente danoso para as
artérias e pode causar coagulos
perigosos por isso é importante escolher
a manteiga como opção ao invés da
margarina o alimento número cinco é
bebida é o álcool o álcool em excesso é
um grande vilão elevando os níveis de
inflamação no corpo e os níveis de
proteína ser reativa que é um marcador
inflamatório então o consumo excessivo
de álcool pode causar arritmias
intoxicação no fígado cirrose e
resistência à insulina Além disso ele
aumenta a pressão arterial e
sobrecarrega o sistema vascular
comprometendo seriamente a saúde das
suas veas e artérias pessoal as bebidas
alcoólicas em geral tem um efeito
diurético quando consumidas em acesso
levando a perda de líquido Magnésio e
potássio através da urina como eu já
expliquei potássio e magnésio são
minerais são eletrólitos fundamentais
pra saúde arterial saúde cardiovascular
então alimento número seis é na
realidade um conjunto os Fast Foods são
aqueles combos que você compra e come
nas lanchonetes do palhaço como
hambúrguer industrializado batata fr que
quase não tem batata refrigerante e às
vezes até sorvete ou milkshake esse tipo
de alimento é muito inflamatório
especialmente se você consome com
frequência mesmo que seja duas ou três
vezes na semana esses alimentos são
ricos em carboidratos refinados
conservantes e principalmente gorduras
hidrogenadas e outros tipos de gorduras
artificiais que entopem endurecem suas
artérias então eles também são ricos em
sódio e carboidratos refinados isso vai
contribuir para obesidade diabetes
resistência à insulina todos os fatores
que levam a doenças
cardiovasculares embora o sódio seja um
eletrólito um mineral essencial os
alimentos de fast food contém sódio em
excesso em altas concentrações muitas
vezes um sal de péssima qualidade um sal
comum refinado e não sal Marin integral
que possui outros minerais vitais paraa
saúde então o consumo elevado de sódio
desses alimentos ricos em sódio ricos em
sal refinado pode levar uma deficiência
de outros minerais importantes como
potássio que é fundamental para manter a
pressão arterial regular e o
funcionamento adequado das paredes das
artérias portanto evite esses alimentos
e consuma só de vez em quando esporádico
uma alternativa é preparar suas próprias
versões desses alimentos em casa como
batatas fritas e hambúrgueres de matéria
mais saudável
o alimento número sete são os Biscoitos
ou bolachas recheadas essas bolachas com
recheio bonito e colorido são um dos
piores alimentos pra saúde das artérias
de saúde geral incluindo a saúde
intestinal elas podem contribuir de
forma significativa para doenças
cardíacas e problemas vasculares Você já
percebeu como um biscoito rechado pode
ficar parado por dias meses e até anos
sem apodrecer faça esse teste depois me
conte p Pegue um desses biscoitos
recheados industrializados e marcas
baratas deixe num canto da sua casa
observando quanto tempo ele permanece no
mesmo estado o máximo que pode acontecer
ele amolecer um pouco mas não estraga E
por que que é tão ruim assim porque é
rico em conservantes açúcar gordura
hidrogenada Além disso essas bolachas
contém aditivos pró-inflamatórios como
CMC que é o carboximetil celulose e
polissorbato e
que são usados como espessantes
emulsificantes estudos já demonstram que
esses aditivos sintéticos podem promover
inflamação crônica a principal vilã que
contribui para destruir nossas artérias
e veias portanto realmente fuja desse
tipo de alimento e vite dar paraos seus
filhos o alimento oito que muita gente
vai se surpreender é um grupo de óleos e
azeites que muitas vezes as pessoas
consomem de forma diária eles estão
presentes em vários alimentos izados em
refeições de restaurantes e até em casa
são os óleos vegetais de sementes é o
óleo de soja Girassol canola e milho e
até o azeite de má qualidade Vamos
começar com os alimentos Fritos como
pastel de feira batata frita coxinha de
padaria salgadinhos de pacote e muitos
outros alimentos Ultra processados esses
produtos contém óleos vegetais e de
sementes que são ricos em ácido
linoleico o conhecido tipo de ômega 6
então embora o ômega-6 seja essencial
para nós O problema é que nossa dieta
moderna é excessivamente rica nele
desequilibrando a proporção entre
ômega-6 e ômega-3 o que contribui para
doenças crônicas esses óleos são
utilizados em grandes quantidades na
maioria dos produtos industrializados
nos restaurantes e cozinhas Domésticas
em excesso o ácido linoleico prejudica a
saúde ao promover inflamação nas paredes
das artérias e causando danos celulares
portanto é importante evitar o consumo
excessivo de óleo de soja milho canola e
girassol agora por que que Eu mencionei
o azeite porque muitas pessoas consomem
azeite de má qualidade com misturas
contém então esses óleos vegetais de
sementes misturado com azeite de maior
qualidade essas pessoas acham que estão
consumindo um alimento saudável mas
estão sendo enganadas um azeite de boa
qualidade deve ter baixa acidez ser
extravirgem e ter certificação de
qualidade eu vou deixar na descrição um
vídeo sobre como escolher um azeite de
boa qualidade Então o que usar a
cozinhar use manteiga manteiga
clarificada manteiga Gui azeite de boa
qualidade extravirgem banho de porco e
até cebo bovino evite alimentos Ultra
processados pois normalmente são
carregados esses óleos de semente também
evite comer em restaurantes que utilizam
esses óleos para cozinhar e nos molhos e
temperos lembre-se tudo é uma questão de
equilíbrio não estou dizendo para nunca
mais comer sorvete ou batata frita Mas
tente ver sua alimentação como um todo
Observe o que Você consome em uma semana
inteira e veja se não está incluindo um
pouco desses alimentos aqui e ali que no
final se torna muito se você come várias
vezes na semana o objetivo é manter uma
alimentação mais saudável e natural
possível e quando sentir saudade vontade
de consumir esses alimentos consuma com
bastante moderação comp os
vos a vida de além pode também no
[Música]
canal Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera